what's going on guys today i'm going to
explain every founding titan in the
history of attack on titan
at its full potential the shifter is
pretty much invincible as it has control
over every subject of emir
not to mention all titans and titan
shifters for a hundred years its powers
were severely weakened due to the
varonizing war but luckily for aaron
that vow only affects people who have
royal blood
as a result he can use its true
abilities when the right conditions are
met which is unlike most of his recent
predecessors
by my account there are 10 characters
who have used the founder's power that
we know of
and in this video i'll be going through
the details of each one in the process
we'll discuss the different ways they've
used it
and where the power of the titans even
comes from but spoiler went ahead for
the second half of the final season
if you're interested in more content
like this then do check out my attack on
titan playlist since i've now done a
video on all of the night shifters
okay so the first person on this list is
yamir fritz who was the original
founding titan from nearly 2000 years
ago
for a long time it was speculated that
her abilities came from some kind of
deal with the devil
but i would argue the truth is even more
bizarre in the beginning emir was a
powerless child from a random village
however one day her people were attacked
by a tribe known as the aldians
this tribe was led by a man called carl
fritz and they proceeded to kill
yamiya's parents
cut out her tongue and capture her as a
slave for good measure
soon afterwards she was made to perform
various tasks for the aliens alongside
the other slaves and this included
things like transporting jugs of water
and looking after the pigs
on one fateful day she intentionally
left the gate of the pigpen open
allowing one of the pigs to escape and
this decision although it seemed
harmless at first
unfortunately that choice would lead to
billions and billions of deaths
by letting the animal go she was almost
immediately blamed for it and aldean
soldiers were sent by fritz to chase her
through the forests
even though the situation seemed
hopeless a wounded yamir continued to
stumble forward to survive
and this is where we come to the origin
of the titans in chapter 137
zeke gave armin a lesson about how life
on earth began and during that monologue
we saw these organisms in the sea
the one on the left made a brief
appearance during the season 2 opening
but the creature in the center is the
real one we need to talk about
this type of worm is referred to as
hallucigenia which is an extinct species
that existed hundreds of millions of
years ago in the real world
in the attack on titan universe though a
large mutated version of this creature
existed during ymir's lifetime
and had the power to largen other things
within the ldm forest there was a
massive tree that stood high above all
others
and its size was likely caused by the
hallucinogenia living underneath it
of course simia herself had no reason to
suspect anything so she walked into this
tree thinking she'd have a place to hide
but soon fell down into the water below
as she desperately struggled for breath
the mutant worm quickly approached her
and fused itself into her spine
this merging of human and hustygenia is
what led to the creation of the first
founding titan
with her invincible body towering over
everything in sight in terms of her
design
this original titan had distinctive
features that we don't often see
like her protruding ribs and the fact
her skull has no flesh whatsoever
while there is no official confirmation
on her size i'd estimate that she's at
least taller than the colossal although
let me know in the comments
what you think her exact height might be
now despite her newfound power ymir
returned to serve carl fritz in what was
a strange turn of events
you'd assume she'd want revenge for him
enslaving her and destroying her
hometown
but instead she went on to obey him as a
titan for the following 13 years her
titan body also helped to build roads
bridges and anything useful to ld's
expansion
but importantly she didn't have access
to the coordinates full abilities
this will become clearer as the video
goes on but most of the founders powers
only work on subjects of ymir who are
the people descended from emir herself
regular human beings are totally
unaffected by things like memory
manipulation for example
so at this point in history she couldn't
use his true potential regardless of
that
the earlier empire was still able to
expand at a ridiculously fast rate
and king fritz became a very powerful
individual ymir would go on to have
three of his children over the years
with their names being mario rose and
sheena which may sound familiar because
the wars on parodies were named after
them
on the day their mother died the king
was addressing his soldiers in the
military
when one of them rose up and straight up
tried to assassinate him he threw a
spirit fritz with pinpoint accuracy
but ymir herself jumped in the way and
took the fatal blow while this was a
serious injury
it's conceivable that a titan shifters
should be able to survive this as long
as they have the will to live
it's probable that you yamir's will to
live vanish when she looked up at king
fritz
as the two of them made direct eye
contact after she was attacked
in that moment her daughters were crying
but the king himself showed no emotion
despite the fact she just saved his life
he simply told her to stand up and get
back to work and only when she heard
this did our eyes begin to close
her soul was reborn in what we now know
to be the past dimension and from there
she would have probably the worst job of
all time
in all the times people have been using
the titans it was ymir who was creating
those titan bodies out of sand
and then sending the flesh and bones to
that person through parts
in the final chapter armin questioned
why you may will continue to obey fritz
and do all these things for 2000 years
with aaron confirming it was because she
loved him clearly we know the king did
not love her back
but in dying she still followed his
final order to work because she felt
connected to the wall she left behind
before we move on to the next founding
titan we should probably mention the
curse of emir which is something that
affects all titan shifters
since she died 13 years after getting
her titan none of her descendants are
able to surpass the length of time
with their bodies deteriorating when the
time gets closer admittedly this affects
different people in different ways
as grisha jaeger looked pretty normal
when his time was about to run out
whereas uri rice was in his 30s looking
like he was about to drop dead
it's unclear why exactly the curse of
ymir exists i mean does he may
intentionally make that happen or is it
the will of the coordinate
i mean we just don't know but either way
it's an unavoidable thing that every
shifter goes through
with that said the second founding titan
we know about is one of vimeo's
daughters
and i'm going to explain how this led to
the creation of the present day royal
bloodline
after yamir's death fritz was desperate
for the titans not to disappear
so he forced his daughters to eat every
last piece of our body
this is similar to how people in the
present will turn into pure titans
before eating a shifter
but the main thing they have in common
is that you need to eat the spine the
spine is of course where the lusugenia
first connected to ymir
so by mario rosenshine eating it the
titan powers were split between them
two of them would have inherited hybrid
titans that are a mix of the eight
shifters we know today
but only one child would have inherited
the true founding titan
as gabby said this ancient worm is the
coordinate so it lived on inside
whichever sister had the founder
while the other two shifters were simply
connected to it this ties into the topic
of the royal bloodline which has always
been one of the more convoluted aspects
of this series
by now we should know that only those
with royal blood can activate the
founders true potential by themselves
whereas for normies like erin there are
more steps involved the problem with
this is that if you go all the way back
every subject of emir derives from these
two common ancestors
meaning that you know whichever ldn
you're looking at they all have fritz's
blood inside them no matter how small it
may be
why is it then that eldians like zika
considered to be royalty
whereas everyone else doesn't get those
same benefits one line of thinking is
that maybe not all of the daughters were
fritz's children
although i personally doubt that theory
because i mean he really thought they
were his daughters
and it's inconceivable that yamir would
cheat therefore
my own theory as to why certain
characters have royal blood can be
traced back to this moment in the past
dimension
here we see the coordinate in the center
and out of there are three separate
parts
each one representing mario rose and
sheena respectively
although all three of them technically
have royal blood like i said earlier
only one of these daughters inherited
the founder's power
and carried on the fritz family name
purely for example
if we assume that mario is the sister
that had the founding titan
her children and her children's children
would be the ones that you may consider
to be royal blooded
since that offshoot of the family would
repeatedly go to pars and tell her what
to do
it was individuals from their specific
branch of the family that gave him your
orders for the next two thousand years
and this lineage continued all the way
up until historia and zeke
no matter how many subjects of emir
there might be it also traces back to
these three branches
so i feel like this could explain the
difference between who ymir does and
doesn't choose to obey
i suspect that when an alden like grisha
has a baby with a royal
that child is added to maori's branch of
the tree but in any other scenario a
child is born to the rose or sheena path
instead
anyway the third founding titan in this
video was an aldean king from 600 years
before the present day of the series
salva spoke about this king in season 4
and how he used the coordinate to alter
the bodies of
every subject of emir at the time the
world was being ravaged by a deadly
disease
but overnight the king redesigned the
bodies of millions of aldeans so that
they were all totally immune
this body modification is one of the
founders most wide-ranging abilities
and unsurprisingly it has also been used
to create pure titans throughout history
zeke's power to make pure titans himself
is a lesser version of that same ability
since his scream only works on those
who've ingested his spinal fluid
the fourth founder we know is carl fritz
who was the 145th king of the alien
empire and the one who ruined everything
don't get me wrong by now the aliens
have been a menace to the world for a
long time
but carl's solution to this problem was
less than ideal i mean just ask anyone
who died in the first three seasons
during willy type his big production he
got an actor to play the role of fritz
and this speech gave us an insight into
the former king's mentality
carl was a guy who felt immense guilt
for the sins of the eldian race
since for years they've been forcibly
spreading the blood of emir across the
globe
and then using titans to wipe out entire
groups of people he felt immense
sympathy for mali in particular
and believed that nothing lda could do
could atone for the lives they've
destroyed
to add to all of this the great titan
war was also raging on during carl's
lifetime
in which the noble families of elia had
a civil war using the other eight titan
shifters
this was essentially the final straw for
him as the infighting made him realize
that the titan powers especially the
founder
must be kept out of human hands his
solution to all of this began when he
inherited the coordinate himself
as he conspired to take down the alien
empire there were many different stages
to fritz's plan
but it started when he guaranteed the
type of family's safety in exchange for
them helping marley to take back control
together they made up a fake marion hero
named helos who would go on to be known
as the one who defeated elder with the
help of the tigers
the story goes that hellos manipulated
different noble families into killing
each other
and then somehow forced fritz to retreat
to paradise island in reality the king
wanted to flee to the island
and he brought with him as many aliens
as he could not to mention many
non-subjects of emir such as the asian
clan and also those who would later be
known as nobles
it goes without saying that he would
still leave many of his people behind on
the continent
as well as members of the royal family
who were late to be whittled down to
just zeke
in the king's absence the alien empire
continued to crumble and the tigers
assisted mali in stealing seven of the
nine shifters for itself
with the attack titan being the only one
to evade capture
back on the island itself fritz wanted
to create a peaceful society free of war
and he used the founder's power to try
and make that a reality his first action
was to materialize
tens of millions of colossus titans
which i imagine took you mere quite a
long time in paths
when those titans were in position carl
utilized their hardening ability to
erect the three wars we know today
and their names were of course mario
rose and sheena within these wars is
where his new society would be made to
live
but in true thanos style the king didn't
think it could be paradise if people
still remembered what existed before
that's why he transformed into his
founding titan and erased the memories
of nearly all people on the island
he made them believe they were the last
survivors of the human race and that
these walls were constructed to protect
them from the titans
on the flip side though the ackermanns
were among a select group of families
unaffected
by the king's memory manipulation their
knowledge of the outside world was a
threat to the paradise that carl was
trying to create
so he offered them noble status and
privilege to guarantee their silence
while some bloodlines accepted this
offer the acumens and asians rejected it
as they disagreed with the king's
ideology the king did not take this well
as you can understand
and to preserve his definition of peace
karl had them hunted down through the
generations until there were virtually
none left
hence why there was only one half asian
and a handful of acumens in the present
day
now in an act of self-protection the
king then changed the royal family's
name from fritz to rice
and then he had a random noble family
take on the fritz name instead
the new fritz family would pretend to be
the monarchs for the next 100 years
but in reality it would be the rice's
who were really in charge behind the
scenes
some time after this carl used his
abilities again to create the rice
chapel which is where the royals passed
on the coordinate for generations
at least until grisha rudely interrupted
them overall the king's mindset was that
lds pass crimes could never be forgiven
and that he would accept it if marley
one day came to destroy the island
his dream was to limit a peaceful
society until that day comes and by
making a vow to announce war
future founding titans were possessed by
that same ideology
last thing to mention on carl is that he
made a threat to the world that he would
activate the rumbling if they tried to
attack
however as willy tyber revealed that was
just a empty threat and he only said it
to prolong the peace on parodies
fast forward many decades later and the
next founder we saw was an unnamed man
from the royal family
he was the father to both rod and uri
rice both of whom would constantly beg
him to eradicate the pure titans
due to the var announcing war he never
once made an attempt to do this
which is something his sons couldn't
understand based on his personal library
here he clearly enjoyed reading but when
what bothered him too much he'd lock his
son inside a dungeon
doesn't really seem like a proportionate
response but you know if you're the king
of the walls i guess you can do what you
want
eventually the time came for one of his
sons to become the next founder and uri
was certain he'd be able to do what his
father couldn't
sadly though after inheriting this titan
he was immediately consumed by carl
fritz's vow announcing war and never
spoke again about destroying the titans
outside the walls
in a flashback scene we got a small look
at the design of his founding titan
although the form was mostly incomplete
on this day the two rush brothers have
been travelling together
but were ambushed by kenny ackerman who
was given their location by a royal
government official
knowing they had been betrayed by
someone the king was eager to find out
who told kenny where they'd be
but he couldn't use the founder's power
to make him talk as an ackerman kenny
was immune from those type of mind games
which like i said is part of the reason
they were hunted down and persecuted
uri therefore understood why someone
from that clan would want to kill him
which is why even with a knife in his
arm it was the king who apologized and
bowed down
following this encounter the two of them
actually became friends with uri putting
an end to the ackerman's persecution
at least in a official capacity he then
hired kenny to be a fixer for the rice
family
and over the years it's implied the two
of them were quite candid with each
other with the king even telling him
that his power was going to be
transferred
during his time as the founding titan
uri frequently gave sermons about peace
to those within his inner circle
including the interior police and of
course kenny as his 13 years came closer
to an end the curse of emir really
started to make him look like an old man
he had gray hair wrinkles and a walking
stick which means his titan regeneration
must have also been getting really slow
with old age
one interesting thing about uri is that
he predicted the world would be
destroyed in the not too distant future
and at first i thought this statement
referred to the warriors invading the
island
given the context we have now though
it's likely assayama wrote this line
with the rumbling on his mind instead
moving on frida rice became the new
founding titan in the year 842
and just like uri she thought she could
overcome the will of carl fritz
spoiler alert she couldn't but let's
explain who she is in the first place
by all accounts freda was one of the
nicest characters in the series and was
the eldest daughter of rod rice
whereas rod completely ignored the
existence of his youngest child historia
it was friday that went out of her way
to teach the girl to read ride and ride
horses
in many ways it was her influence that
made historia the humble person she
became
and at the age of 15 frida inherited the
founding titan choosing to eat your
uncle is never an easy decision
but she did it to save humanity from the
titans because like i said
she thought she could override the
varanasi war after gaining the founder
she would begin to give speeches like
her uncle used to do
and in her spare time she played with
historia and then wiped her memory
afterwards
she did this to protect her younger
half-sister since being of royal blood
does tend to put a target on someone's
back
historian noted how sometimes friday
would act like a totally different
person
and these moments were when the king's
will was the strongest the best example
in my opinion
is when grisha confronted her in the
rice chapel cause frida's entire speech
was literally spoken
as if it was culprits himself in terms
of her founding titan's design
she didn't have the exposed ribs or long
arms of her predecessors
and her height was slightly shorter than
gris's attack titan
as a result of the var announcing war
she was defeated pretty easily by grisha
even though her shifter is in theory
meant to be unbeatable
on a random note there was that one
occasion when aaron witnessed a memory
of frida brushing her hair
and the anime definitely made it seem
like she saw him looking at her
whether she actually did or not is up
for debate because as grisha said she
never really had access to the founder's
full potential
given that the var announcing war
severely limits what she can do
following that fight the eighth founder
in this video is of course grisha jaeger
who is responsible for merging the
attack titan and the founding titan
into one body all things considered he
had this power for a really short
time as he stole it from frida and then
forcibly made aaron eat him not long
after that
there was never really a scenario in
which grisha could have actually used
the coordinate but rather his sole
purpose was to transfer the power from
the rice family to the jaegers
being an alden restorationist he'd
wanted his titan taken from the royal
family for a long time
but i'm sure he never imagined it would
be up to him given that he wanted his
wife to take it at first and then he
wanted his son to take it
but no he ended up being the one trusted
to do it to his credit he did locate the
true royal family after only a few years
which when you compare that to marley's
four warriors i mean first of all it's
way more impressive
and i kind of think they might have been
more successful if they sent experienced
adults like grisha or people like that
rather than 12 year old kids anyway on
the first occasion he visited the rice
chapel he chose not to confront the
royals for the sake of his family
but he would eventually return on the
day marley invaded as i explained in my
video about every attack titan
it was eren from the future that
motivated grisha to kill frieder in the
first place
but that wouldn't have been possible
without the unknowing help of grisha's
first son
z kyge is the next person on this list
to have used the finest power and he was
the first royal in over a century to
have access to its full potential
while it is true that he didn't have a
physical founding titan body his use of
its power is still an essential part of
the story that can't be overlooked
a while ago it was established that if a
titan of royal blood makes contact with
the founder
then that person can get around its
limitations we witnessed this first time
when aaron commanded an army of pure
titans after touching daniel fritz
despite the fact he's a regular aldian
who shouldn't be able to use the
coordinate
the second time aaron touched a royal
bloody titan was when his decapitated
head fell into zeke's hands
but this time there was a twist unlike
previous royals
zeke arrived here without being tainted
by the will of king fritz meaning he was
free to command yumir however he wanted
after spending a long time in this realm
before aaron arrived he learned about
the extent of yumi's abilities
and how she is a slave to royal blooded
individuals on a basic level
whoever ymir listens to is the one that
controls the founder and she initially
listened to zeke because he has royal
blood
in his very brief time in charge of the
founder the ld sega brother tried to use
this power for four main things
number one is that he created these
easily breakable chains around his body
as he wanted to pretend he was trapped
by the voucher announced war
this was part of zeke's test to see if
aaron was really on his side and it was
a test that was very quickly failed
number two is that he made some actual
change to restrict eren and these ones
were so tough that aaron had to rip his
thumbs off to break free
the third and most game-changing use of
this power was when he physically took
his brother into their father's memories
since he was trying to prove that
grisham had brainwashed aaron by doing
this
zeke unknowingly gave his brother the
chance to talk to the memory of their
father and then send that message back
to the real grisha in the past
the real grisha was able to see those
memories due to the future memory
inheritance of the attack titan
but zeke never knew this could happen
because he didn't know about that
ability
in this way aaron was able to manipulate
the past and make his father kill frieda
however it was only possible because
zeke took aaron into that memory in the
first place
the fourth way zeke tried to use the
founder was more of a fail as he
commanded jimmy to sterilize all aliens
across the globe
this had been his plan since he was a
teenager yet it didn't work out because
aaron spoke to the founder as a person
convincing you that she should choose
what happens next rather than simply
being a slave to the royal bloodline
zeke desperately tried to convince her
to still follow him but by then she had
already chosen aaron's side
and the founders power awakened in him
soon afterwards it's crazy how all those
events happened in a split second in
reality but in the past
dimension it was clearly a notable
period of time in any case
the last founding titan is erin yeager
who is a character that needs no
introduction
with yamir on his side he was able to
unleash the full power of the coordinate
in what was the biggest spectacle we've
ever seen his first action was to undo
all titan hardening in the world
which included not just the wars on
paradise but also the armor titan's
armor fell apart
and annie's crystal came undone as well
he then used the founding titan in a way
we've never seen before
since he telepathically sent a message
to every alien on the planet
millions upon millions of subjects were
summoned to the past dimension
regardless of where they were in the
real world
and aaron proceeded to tell them his
intention to end life outside the walls
this telepathic ability was then put to
use even further as aaron later spent
time visiting each of his friends to say
goodbye
during this goodbye tour he showed armin
the amazing natural landscapes that they
spoke about when they were kids
and for mikasa he made a world in which
they lived in a cabin in the woods
one thing that's so clear is whether
erin is able to just create these
environments literally out of nothing
or if he's simply showing the memories
from eldins of the past in a similar way
to how zeke took them into grisha's
memories
regardless of the way he does it it's
possible these two could have spent a
longer time in part than what we saw in
the final chapter
given that time passes faster in there
compared to the real world
speaking of time error noted how the
founders powers make him experience the
past present and future simultaneously
this is why he's unable to deviate from
the end result where he dies
because it's all a fixed timeline that
can only have one outcome
this is where we get to one of his most
controversial uses of the founding titan
which was aaron influencing the past to
make sure the events of the first
episode happened
this reveal was foreshadowed back in
season 4 when the dynafritz titan
bizarrely walked straight past bertolt
despite being a pure titan
these paths transcend time itself so he
used this ability to preserve the fixed
timeline
in his words he had to do it since it
wasn't berto's time to die
and the official translation makes it
clear that eren made diner then go in
the direction of his home
this is of course so that she can go to
his house and eat his mother and in the
process
put young aaron on the path he needs to
go on as i said in my review of the
final chapter
it's not like future aaron wanted to do
these things it's just that he can't
fight against a past and a future
that was already predetermined when he
kissed historia's hand
that was the first time he saw dino
fritz's memory of bertolt from her
perspective
and initially it was confusing why aaron
was seeing this but now we know why
in terms of the design of eren's
founding titan it was quite easily the
largest titan in history
making even the colossal look tiny by
comparison its main body is nearly
identical in shape to the hallucigenia
and this is possibly due to the way this
shifter was created
if we go back when aaron and zeke
touched each other i mean aaron was just
ahead
so this worm needed to create a brand
new titan body from scratch
with the end result being a bony
creature similar to its own design
each of these bones act like legs that
slowly move forward and at the very
front of the body we have aaron himself
in my opinion the overall design of this
titan is literally a metaphor for how he
doesn't have any free will
hear me out here most of the body is in
the shape of this ancient worm
which itself represents the power of the
founder it was this
same power that robbed aaron of his
freedom since it gave him an inevitable
fate he could never deviate from
at the front of the body aaron presents
himself as the one being in charge but
when we look at his arms they're being
held up by something
just like a puppet on a string aaron is
being controlled by the founding titan
and the way his arms are hanging draw
direct parallels with this
the string holding him up originates
from the hallucigenia so it further hits
home that he is simply a puppet of the
founding titan
moving on the coordinates next ability
was shown in the final battle
when it began resurrecting shifters from
the past these ancient titans were
summoned by yamir to defend aaron
and the story made it clear they weren't
just minus zombies although most of them
did do what yamir wanted
it really didn't take much convincing
for others to switch sides and fight
with the alliance
bertolt sarva and grisha and also many
other characters
they all rallied behind those who were
trying to stop the rumbling indicating
that they did have some form of
consciousness
and were able to reject what ymir wanted
other powers include being able to
replicate the form of any other titan
evidence when aaron himself made a brand
new colossal body this ability shouldn't
be too surprising
given the way the coordinate was used to
make millions of titans on a whim
however it is still strange seeing
aaron's head on this particular titan
towards the climax of attack on titan it
was also made very clear that if he
wanted to
he could remove the shifter abilities
from the other eight titans
ultimately he didn't do this since there
was no other way they even had a chance
of beating him
but the option was always there in the
penultimate chapter
the hallucigenia produced a gas that
turns aliens into pure titans
and this works on any subject except for
acumens or titan shifters
it's safe for us to assume the founders
of the past could do a similar thing
as this is very likely where miley got
inspiration from to try it themselves
final thing to mention before we end the
video is that the real aaron was located
in the mouth of his founding titan
and was connected to the body via his
spine and these weird fleshy appendages
after mikasa killed him the symbiotic
ancient worm also disappeared
putting a seemingly permanent end to the
power of the titans
as always thank you guys for watching
this video on all founding titans in
history and be sure to smash that sub
button if you want to see more stuff
like this
i'd also appreciate if you hit that like
button as well as it does help out the
video
and until the next one peace out